Iraqi Kurdistan's independence
referendum may seem like the culmination
of a century long dream if it were to
happen the outcome would be clear but
why is the United States and the
international community so opposed the
problem is determining what is kurdistan
the world recognizes Erbil soleimani and
de Hoch is Kurdish but the referendum
includes other areas claimed by the
Iraqis that means an immediate fight
over borders then there's the economy
Kurdistan is twenty billion dollars in
debt it is less oil than the rest of
Iraq and landlocked it would be at its
neighbours mercy after independence it
will not only lose its 17 percent claim
to ear ox revenues but Baghdad will also
demand it pay a share of e-rock stead
simply put it's not going to be able to
pay its teachers soldiers and
bureaucrats the biggest problem will be
its neighbors both Turkey and Iran fear
the precedent independence would have
upon their own Kurdish minorities Iran
can destabilize its new neighbour and
Turkey can send in troops political
divisions among the Kurdish pesh MERGA
further undermine hope for stability so
here's the question for Washington
Americans might sympathize with Kurdish
aspirations but will America fund and
fight for them to learn more about my
take on Kurdistan and Kurdish issues
check the links in the description below
and if you enjoyed the video be sure to
LIKE and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI